[Applause]
the hands-on favorite in the eurovision
song contest ukraine's kalush orchestra
rehearses for the biggest performance of
their lives
they're carrying the hopes of their
country devastated by russia's war
against ukraine
in any year their song stefania a fusion
of rap and ukrainian folk music would
have probably been a hit it's an ode to
the lead singer's mother but with the
war raging it's taken on new meaning
indeed the song stephanie was written
long before the war and it was dedicated
to my mother
after it all started with the war and
the hostilities it took on an additional
meaning and many people started seeing
it as their mother
ukraine
the all-male band was given special
permission to leave ukraine one of its
members is still fighting in keith
ukrainian fans in italy say a win here
would mean everything the eurovision is
like a bridge to that normal life that
we have before the war started and maybe
like for a couple of minutes for an hour
a day we could just feel safe and normal
it would mean a lot it would mean a lot
stephanie i turned into
a
song about
everyone's mom and ukraine as a mom mom
to us all and we are singing about
mom that we are fighting for
but victory is not a sure thing of
course there are 24 other finalists
taking the stage in turin on saturday
the uk's sam rider a tick-tock star has
generated buzz too as has norway's
subwoofer for their song and their
antics
making finals iceland's entrant said it
makes sense for larger events to be
front and center
[Applause]
[Music]
we really wanted to bring hope
to people suffering and
the people that are not free
and the people that are going to through
hard times like ukraine
and
to all of us that have been struggling
and and covet
that there's hope for the tens of
thousands of fans here at the finals and
the millions more watching at home it's
always about the music it's just that
this year the music has taken on greater
significance than normal adam rainey al
jazeera turin italy